hey everybody is Jessie my streams a
little bit there's something on my
stream YouTube's telling me that it's
bad so let me know if the streams not
working I could try to restart it I
think what happened is I just had way
too many browser tabs open and my
computer started to to lag a little bit
and slow down at that point it started
to tell me the stream was bad so I was
frantically trying to close tabs before
two o'clock hit so hopefully it'll start
working again pull everybody everybody's
saying hi in the live chat so if you've
been watching the last couple of days
seems like every day I get a question
from somebody in the live chat about
react what are we going to do react and
I've been saying we're going to do react
and we're finally doing it so as you can
see if you saw yesterday my my Trello
board here where I keep the track of
everything the done column has a lot
more things in it yesterday I put in an
epic day of work thirteen and a half
hours of work most of that time was
actually spent on this site I did have
some meetings and things like that so I
didn't code the entire time but I got
the site to a point where everything is
pretty much in place aside from some
minor minor details there's still some
demo content that I just don't have yet
there's some images that need to be
resized but for the most part everything
everything is pretty much how it's going
to be when we go alive I'm sure they'll
be some last-minute changes there always
are Internet is paid for today so close
for you okay sorry I had some people
saying they couldn't hear anything some
people saying the Internet's very
for other people were saying it's okay
so all right just just let me know if it
sounds if it's really messed up you know
put it in a live chat the the control
room on YouTube is still telling me that
my stream status is bad but my computer
seems to be running okay again this
happened one time before when i refresh
the page I stopped the stream and
started it it said it was good again I
don't want to try to do that right in
the middle of the stream now normally I
would figure this out before I started
the stream but it this actually have in
one minute before the stream was
supposed to start so as long as it seems
like mostly you're having an okay time
with this dream it's it's working so I'm
just going to leave it alone for now um
but anyway yes so the site's pretty much
where it where it needs to be I'll give
you just real quick I'll just go over
some of the stuff that I did you can
check it out all the links are in the
description uh I added a couple links
for for react and for next yeah that's
what we're going to go over today so the
home page pretty much the same as it was
I added this here at the bottom these
are little tabs these tabs this kind of
style of tab that comes built in with
materialized it's the framework we're
using these cards are going to be
clickable links and it'll switch back
and forth between these two categories
we have the the footer is now populated
with the things it needs to be populated
with I added this in the top this was a
mandatory for me to add in we tried to
add add this into a lot of our websites
to have you know at least something
uniform branding wise on all the sites
you see the other page I'm not going to
go into all the pages I'm afraid if I
start going into it I'll spend half the
time just going over the site when you
guys can check this out on get up right
now
so let's jump into react so today I'm
going to be working on the command line
a lot which I haven't done previously so
this is item 2 is what I use for the
command line I'm on a Mac so I just all
I did there was just open up a new tab
so we'll start fresh on this side of the
screen let me know if any of this is too
small I can make it bigger I'm just
going to increase the font size a bit on
everything okay so we're starting out
blank slate command line I've had a lot
of people request to start out from just
totally from scratch so some of the
things that I already did do so it's not
completely from scratch so let's say you
just got your Mac or I mean these could
probably same steps would probably work
on Linux as well it's slightly different
for a PC but not too different so you
should be able to follow along for the
most part let's say you got it fresh
which you would need to do is install
obviously I installed item 2 but you
could just use the regular terminal that
comes with mag and you'll want to
install node.js so you just go to the
node.js website there's instructions for
downloading that so you have node and
then you'll need NPM I think NPM comes
prepackaged with node but it's been so
long since I installed it on maybe it's
a separate install but if you have those
two things that's pretty much all you
need to get to the point where I'm at
today
so not exactly from scratch but pretty
close so right now I'm at the command
line I'm going to go in I keep
everything in projects so I'm gonna go
to my projects folder and I'm going to
make a new directory and let's call this
CI for catechetical Institute that's the
name of the site and we'll call this
react
okay so let's CD into that that
directory
okay so now we're in in the director
we need at this point we're pretty much
ready to go into the directions for next
jazz okay so if you're not familiar with
next basically it does a lot of things
but the reason I'm using it is for his
two main reasons one it handles your
server side server side rendering that's
important for search engines to be able
to see your content the second reason is
it just lets you jump start react
development it loads a lot of things for
you so that you don't have to do it one
by one there are a lot of other things
that do something similar react actually
has things create rack react app that
does the same thing and you can see more
about react here's Facebook github dot
and the links in the description so you
can learn more about react from the
website and I'll probably do some videos
some pre-recorded videos on it when I
get a chance but we're starting with
next this is just its github page so
let's let's set this up I'm going to use
instead of NPM I'm actually going to use
yarn it basically does the same thing as
NPM it's just a little bit faster and it
has this lock file that that has some
other benefits I personally have never
had any issues with different different
repos and NPM like the conflicts between
packaged versions but yarn takes care of
all that for you so you will have to
install so yarn I link to that in the
description as well alright so I'm just
going to go yarn so I wonder for NPM it
would be NPM what is it in it let's see
if I just go yarn if it'll do it
nothing to install sorry I can't
remember would be okay so we're doing a
yarn in it basically this will create
the package.json file that we see here
so we need to add this script to
package.json I guess I could have they
could have just installed this but let's
see CI react that's a good name when you
do this it'll just ask you a couple
questions you can actually just skip
most of this and I will for the for this
video I'm just going to skip most of
this but you can fill it out if you want
you can always fill it out later too
okay everybody follow somebody mentioned
UJS I haven't used view jazz yet I keep
seeing it a lot come up in articles and
things I'd like to learn more about it
at some point okay so we have let me do
this okay so now we have this package
JSON file I'm just going to
let's go yarn add so with NPM you go NPM
install with yarn is different you say
yarn add and I'm going to add next react
and react on so now a yarn is doing its
thing I've no idea how long this will
take it's been a couple months since
I've gone through this process also it's
been a few months since I installed next
and it's exchange just it's a couple
versions ahead so this is unscripted and
live so if we run into any issues sorry
but that's kind of the point of the
videos just to show you what I do even
if I mess up alright so you see how fast
that was that was actually faster and I
thought it would be and all this stuff
got installed
which is pretty awesome because I would
I don't know how long that would take me
to install this one by one so everything
is installed we can see we have a few
more things here we have our node
modules our package JSON and we have our
lock file we'll never directly edit the
lock file and probably never even look
at it
occasionally we'll need to edit our
package JSON and we'll never directly
interact with node modules but for now
let's open our package JSON file so I'm
going to I'm actually going to go Adam
dot and that's my my code editor and if
I do that it will open up my code editor
in this case I'll topping out another
screen I'm gonna have to pull it over in
a second alright so let's pull this over
and we'll just make that fullscreen for
now so here's our package JSON file you
can see it tells us we have this is some
of the stuff that we skipped over and
didn't fill and it just gave us default
things but then here's our dependencies
this section will tell us everything
we've installed all our packages so we
have next we have react we act on them
here and this tells us our versions okay
so we're good the next step we'll go so
I let me organize this a little better
for us okay never mind
I see where it went it went behind so
I'm going to minimize that there we go
okay so we need to add this section and
these are going to give us some commands
we can use straight from the terminal to
start our react app to build it to get
it ready for production and then to
start it as a production app so let's
put that in
- put it down below here and actually I
don't think I need these tags do I there
yeah that's why I was discovered yeah so
I copied in some stuff I didn't need
okay but these scripts basically what
I'm going to be able to do is just type
in yarn dev and it'll automatically run
whatever I have on this side of the
colon same way with your unbuild
yarn started you can chain together
things maybe later on we'll get into
some more complicated things with this
so let's save that and let's see that is
that's it I mean that's all you need to
get it to get it running okay basically
well we need an index page so we'll just
use their default index page for now
just to show that it works to make sure
that it works but we need to make a
pages folder so right now we have
nothing
let's make direct three pages and let's
okay so I've just made that file let's
go back over to our editor and see we
now have pages let me increase the size
here okay we have pages on size my size
of the code is increasing but I'm not
getting this to increase I'm not sure
why off to try to figure that out after
the video
I wonder if yeah I'm not getting an
increase so if you can't see this
basically I have a folder called pages
and now I have an index file index j/s
let's let's make sure this is what we
needed okay that should be all we need
for now we're going to save that I'll
explain a little bit more what's going
on in a second let's just get it get it
started okay so now we're gonna do yarn
where's my command line so I just type
yarn run dev and that that runs that
will run this command here next okay so
basically what happens here is it's just
started a server okay it's using webpack
and it's just started the server and it
says it's ready on localhost 3000 so we
should be able to see something here
I'll bring this up hopefully I don't
have anything else running on that port
right now her don't mess it up I've had
that happen before all right this one
this work let me bring this over really
small I'll make it bigger okay welcome
to next jazz okay so it doesn't seem
that impressive we just have one line of
text on a page but this is I guess
technically a react up the minimum react
up and you can see I have a browser
extension to show
we're running I guess the u.s. not work
here we go
so it shows we're running react and
webpack so this is this is react hey
guys sorry I'm annoying the live chat a
little bit I just wanted to to get
through that without messing up the
install so I'm going to scroll through
real quick to see if I missed anything
important in the live chat it's like
hello from Poland Montreal Brazil
through Peru Sao Paulo
Guatemala LA Italy well awesome : gone
to bed
somebody's from Narnia that's great I
love that Ukraine Russia Kansas Pakistan
Netherlands wow we got people from all
over the place awesome okay so I'm going
to explain a little bit about how reacts
specifically next j/s with react works
and if I'm losing anybody if you need me
to go over something more let me know in
the in the live chat there's a bit of a
delay so I may not see it right away
but I'll try to get to it and if I miss
with something that you ask in the live
chat put it in the comments I always go
back and read those comments and I'll
respond as soon as I can ok so basically
when you're using next let me move this
out here and let's let's check out the
structure so when you're using next
anything you put in this pages folder
will be a route that will actually be a
page in your app and you are in your
website and we next takes care of all
the routing for that so it's definitely
can only appreciate if you're done
without an extra create like that
anytime soon okay so I got distracted by
the live chat again someone had a good
comment in here so you can only
appreciate it if you
it without next or trait wrecked react
app it can be really time-consuming so
yes that is definitely true when I first
was trying to learn react and I'll say
right up front I am nowhere near an
expert at react I'm still in a learning
process but when I was really really a
newb it react I attempted it several
times to do it from scratch with no help
and pretty much failed I don't even
remember what the result was so it was
it wasn't memorable at all but I tried
create react app and that was awesome
and then I found next and basically I
went with next because of the
server-side rendering became you know
out of the box because I needed that for
a project I was doing a few months ago
so most awaited video yeah I know
everybody wanted the reacts though so
anyway yeah I mean at some point if you
have the time go ahead and try to do
react just straight from scratch there's
value in knowing how to do that and how
to set things up exactly like you need
to but the reality is you just don't
always have time I don't know about you
but a lot of the projects that I work on
just there's just really tight deadlines
and I don't have time to do it exactly
the way I would want to if I have you
know all the time in the world so this
is a great time-saver let's go in and
let's let's make let's make some other
pages and I'm going to duplicate this
tab so this is kind of cool about item
two I'm sure other terminal applications
do this but since I'm running the server
now I can't type any commands without
stopping this so I just open up a new
tab and then I can still check on how
the server is going and I have this new
tab here so I'm just going to I'm going
to CD into this pages directory since
we're going to do some stuff in here and
let's just make some of the pages that I
know we're going to need and you notice
these aren't dot HTML all these are dot
j/s so you're not going to have any
you got HTML pages and your react app
about what did we need a team and I'm
going to bring up on my other screen all
the all the menu links that we'll need I
don't need to add them all right now but
it would be good to get some some
examples okay so we have team we need
courses advanced resources okay that's
good for now okay so now if you can see
all these have been created and I'm
going to go in and let's see I should be
able to let's just pop this same code in
there and we'll just change one word to
let us know that it's actually working
before we get into action you bring it
over content the next couple videos are
going to actually be converting that
static site that we built the last week
converting that into react components I
don't think we're gonna have time to get
into that now we only have about seven
minutes left
okay so sorry arranging some stuff on my
other screens here let's switch back
here and we'll just fill this in I guess
we do this one first just to make sure
it works and I'll just write about
okay so I'll bring this over so check
that out I've typed in it might be hard
to see here at the top but I've just
it's just localhost 3000 slash about and
that's our page that's what we built so
all that routing is totally taken care
of so I don't know if you've ever tried
to build a routing from scratch either
server side or client side it's
time-consuming and it can be buggy if
you're doing it so I I definitely
recommend going with this I once did a
project where I made a custom router
completely myself and then I totally
redid it and went with something
pre-made even after I built everything
because I realized that this is going to
be so hard to maintain I'm I should go
with some pre-made thing that more
people are going to know how to use
except for just me hey guys get a couple
people saying hi alright so what we're
going to do is let's try to bring in
some we have time let's try to bring in
some code alright I showed you the pages
let me do show you where the components
can live now with next the only folder
that you absolutely need to have named
something specific is the pages folder
so you have to have pages and that's
where the default routing is going to
take place in you can name your other
folders whatever you want I'm just going
to name a folder just kind of the
default components folder so I'm going
to make that folder now and this will
this will be where I keep most of my
components if you had a really complex
site or app you probably would want to
break it down into different folders for
right now I think this should work we're
not going to need a ton of different
components so
and the components folder let's just
make some of the components we know
we're going to need so we're going to
need a header let's let's call it a home
header and let's call the convention
home header so I guess it's been about a
month or two since I've actually worked
with react probably like a month and a
half at least at this point the
convention I believe if I remember
correctly is that your components are
all that they're capitalized so that's
why I'm capitalizing this so we have the
home header remember we had two
different versions of the header and
then let's have I'm just going to say
header for the next one actually let's
call it nav I've been calling it nav
throughout this whole video series so
let's not change it up now and now this
just call this regular jeaious we have a
that stinky nav is called a sticking up
we have that sticky nav we're definitely
going to need a footer and so we have
all these components let me think
we have cards for the team members and
that'll be good for now we're going to
have more components than that but now
we can see we have our components I had
learned weapons okay we had another good
comment someone said they had to learn
web pack to set up react tab they did
learn web pack in the process though
which was good but they said it was
painful I'm definitely with you there
for me coming from using it from first
using grunt and then moving to gulp
and then trying to transition a web pack
it was a tough transition for me that's
that's why this you know next Jas or
something like it like create react
react add it takes that off of you so
you don't have to learn web pack just to
use react if you want to just build
something cool and react just to learn
it or to start out with then you can
just skip that I recommend learning it
at some point though but it doesn't hold
you back from me being able to do
something with react
okay so let's bring up let's bring this
up so we have our components now and
we'll bring up the footer and let me
grab I'm going to try to grab some
boilerplate here for a component
hopefully they have one probably
skipping over something this will
probably work this is a little bit more
than we need but I think this should
give us what we want okay so with a few
minutes okay I have one minute left I'll
just pop this over that's extent
actually that's not exactly what we want
[Music]
yes that happens but like I said this is
unscripted it's not rehearsed beforehand
so I may not be able to get a component
built today although I did get a little
farther than I thought I was pretty sure
that I would mess something up when I
was installing everything since it's
been so long but I'm not seeing it I'm
just going to have to go back to one of
my previous react projects and copy
something from there it's a good whip it
someone says there's a good web pack
tutorial that helped them out a lot if
you could go ahead and and link to that
that might be helpful for everybody if
they don't they're not familiar with web
pack yet need some extra help let me go
the last thing I'll do in this video I'm
going to go real quick to one of my
other repos
and I'm going to just grab some code
from a footer component that I did for
that repo for that project and I'll pull
it in and I use next for that as well
let's find this footer
okay all right so I got it let me copy
this in its going to be a lot at first
but let me show you the basics so um
importing react component from react in
this case I'm importing this let me take
this out because I don't have this
component now edit mother flip project
I'm calling this footer and so and then
at the bottom here I'm exporting footer
that's the basics that you really need
and let me just let me take this out
over low so plug-in error because I
don't have that component
let me just real quick double check to
make sure that okay I don't think I'm
using any other components but this I do
want to keep this in basically all I'm
doing here is just making sure that that
copyright date at the bottom is always
current and I guess I don't I don't need
this right now this is my Google
Analytics tag so obviously I'm going to
use a different one and I don't need
that right now
so let's say that and let me try to
bring in into one of our pages so let's
try about let me import see if this will
work let me see how I do this and I'm
going a couple minutes over I apologize
for that but since we kind of started
this I'd like to just finish up and get
one component linked up here alright so
yeah I'm just trying to copy and paste
some stuff so I don't mess it up and so
I can go a little bit faster okay so I'm
going to import footer from footer and
let's
let's actually bring this let's see if
this work I'm not sure that this will
work but let's try it out all right it
worked great let me bring this in
everything worked out for me today I
didn't mess anything up so it's a good
day yesterday I was a little off I
messed some stuff up I didn't do my
usual pre stream routine yesterday so I
don't know if you tuned in yesterday I I
don't know if you caught it but I just
felt kind of really off but anyway that
footer component that we made this is
for another one of my my sites that I
did so it's not the same info but you
can see it brought in everything now
what it didn't bring in where any of the
styles because we didn't bring that in
so try to adjust quality video the
screen so blurry by someone saying the
screen is blurry credit risk quality
yeah on my end it does look like the
stream is good at least YouTube's
telling me stream is good it should be a
1080p if it's blurry for you is possible
that it's a it's your connection I'm
pretty new to live-streaming so I might
be mistaken but alright so that's that's
pretty cool so within basically a half
an hour
we went from pretty much nothing to
installing everything we needed for a
server-side rendered react app we
created about what like five pages in
that app and one component we linked
that component up to one of the pages so
we did all that now granted I copy and
pasted a lot of stuff but you can see
how how easily it is to get started with
react it looks good okay sorry
distracted by the live chat again okay
it looks like the video is looking good
to some people okay 728 no problem yeah
as long as you can get 720
it should be readable anything below
that I would think it would be too fuzzy
to read the code and I'm sorry for that
if you're not able to read it right now
it'll be available in about five minutes
to watch the the replay maybe you can
get it to come through better for you
on the recorded version and so thanks
for tuning in everybody I will be back
tomorrow at the same time next week I'm
going to have some some different times
I know I have some a meeting on Monday
at 2:00 so I'll have to reschedule that
and then I'm going to go to a conference
at the end of the week so we'll see
maybe I'll do some video from the
conference I'll be a syntactic on in
Charleston South Carolina
so we'll see I guess let me know if
anybody's interested in seeing video
from that conference maybe I can try to
stream something from my phone or we'll
see how good the Wi-Fi is but I will be
back tomorrow let me know if you have
any suggestions for me or if you need me
to go over something in more depth and
tomorrow we're going to really get into
making a lot of components and making
some pages so it should be fun all right
you're welcome see you guys